My column for New York Magazine
is "Sex Diaries,"
and it's turning into
a docuseries.
You are my next diarist.
-This is the love of my life.
-Hi.
SPEAKER: You're my best friend.
Last night was amazing.
SPEAKER 2: I'm definitely
in love with John.
We're having a threesome!
SPEAKER 3: Maybe I'm a little
addicted to casual sex.
-SPEAKER 4: You like it?
-SPEAKER 5: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER 6: I have been speaking
with someone on TikTok,
and it's time to meet.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 7: I am polyamorous.
For me, that means
I like multiple partners.
SPEAKER 3:
Despite my sluttier tendencies,
I am a sucker for romance.
SPEAKER: I described it
as a flirtatious friendship
that is sexually rewarding.
SPEAKER 8:
I'm anxious about what it's
gonna be like in the bedroom.
SPEAKER 9: I don't know
what's gonna happen.
SPEAKER 10:
Well, it's been a long time
since somebody made me happy.
SPEAKER 11:
The important thing is that
I'm open to all possibilities.
I'm who I'm supposed to be.
Are we having pancakes?
(CHUCKLES)
You know,
I was promised pancakes.